ladies and gentlemen Steve Guttenberg
good evening tonight's Oscars like the
evenings we just witnessed on film is
made up of special moments and images
unforgettable memories that live within
us forever this montage shows us how an
expertly produced documentary ignites
the very same powerful emotions we feel
when we watch a feature film and that
brings us to our next category the
nominees for best achievement in a
documentary feature our eyes on the
prize America's Civil Rights years
bridge to freedom 1965 Callie Crossley
and James a Divini producers Hellfire a
journey from Hiroshima John junker Minh
and John W our producers radio bikinis
Robert Stone producing a stitch for time
Barbra Hrbek and Cyril Christo producers
attend your lunch the wit and legend of
the Algonquin Round Table aviva slesin
producer and the winner is the 10-year
lunch
the Whedon legend of the Algonquin Round
Table aviva slesin producer
in documentaries you thank your funders
because they make it possible I want to
thank the Arthur vining Davis
foundations the National Endowment for
the Arts
CPB WGBH and wnet American masters for
putting this on my list of credits
because the film took 10 years is too
long and so I will spare you or they're
going to get me off the stage however I
made a film about a family of friends in
New York in the 20s it was a good family
they work together they supported each
other they hired each other and they all
became famous this is a ward as to my
own family of friends in New York thank
you very much